works because uh only our life Welcome
to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and Movie
Channel we have jumped literally from
one stream with Harris
to this so I've just told them all stay
with Harris for a little while you can
come and watch just later
um and I don't even know if it's gonna
work and we're gonna go live so we'll
find out in a second let me just have a
quick look
um but anyway
how are you sir hello sir I wanted to
keep quiet until you gave the intro
because uh I do my podcast uh co-host
how are you I'm fine thank you how are
you I'm very very well let's just see if
we're live on both it looks like we're
live
oh yes we are talking Star Trek because
I mean there's been a little bit of uh
controversy I mean God forbid
you know new Star Trek would be
controversial but it has been so let's
just we'll run the intro and then we'll
get into it
[Music]
Davey B is with us thank you sir you
crossed over from the Dark Side
yeah we've literally been
talking on the other channel and just
jumped over here so I grabbed myself a
fresh drink and we're on it you're in
for like three hours tonight you just
love it you just can't keep off the
internet can you just come on it's like
an addiction isn't it in the end you
can't like sort of stuff yeah yeah my
nightly shoot up yeah
anyway so Star Trek who started watching
lower decks again
uh I still not seen all of it yet I've
not seen it or I'm I'm going through
season three I know that they've
released a a
um uh trailer for season four and I've
I've never been the biggest animated fan
I think they're good but it's not quite
my thing but obviously we've had the
ultimate crossover recently so we'll
talk about that well yeah I mean that
episode was just phenomenal and I've
sort of realized though you've got to
watch the end of lower decks because
they start talking about section 31 at
the end 2016. so I'm wondering
is Lower Deck season four gonna set up
the section 31 movie because that's how
this season ended
[Music]
would it be quite a different Dynamic
though I mean I would have thought lower
Dixon section 31 movie would be very
different in its uh approach to this all
that stuff at the end of the episode if
I remember right boingler accidentally
joins that section 31. I think that's
right I watched it a while ago now but
the last episode is very much about
excuse me about six and excuse me but
section 31.
um and then poking but obviously they do
it in their style joking about it and
being silly with it even though the last
couple of episodes were quite you know
more serious than I think but I just
think the way they're doing it with Star
Trek at the moment and we'll talk about
this is with all the different shows
existing within universe as well which
is
confusing disabilities sure yeah
that was the best load episode ever
um I think it was the best strategy was
I think it might be my favorite Star
Trek episode except maybe the last
couple of episodes of Picard season
three I think
High Praise
um it's it was brilliant episode I've
watched it I've watched it twice
um so but I think
it's a perfect opportunity to do
something that gives us I mean it
wouldn't even surprise me if Michelle yo
makes a surprise
um appearance in lower decks next season
it wouldn't Shock Me we don't know where
she went in Discovery she went back in
time somewhere so through the guardian
forever of all things so it's possible
yeah it's possible and to be honest it
might be a way I've always said that
they've got to set that up somehow
because they're now it's a movie that
their intention was to do well first of
all the intention was to do a series and
then Michelle went I'm quite busy so how
about a mini series okay we're gonna do
a mini series then she won the Oscar and
they went TV movie and so now they've
got from 10 hours down to two hours
they've got so they've got to figure out
a way to set that up and I've been
arguing this I've said about this when I
talked about it when it's released I'm
like that's gonna be
difficult unless
you bring the character into lower decks
engineering because it's just using a
voice you mean just use a voice that's
that's like two days work
she could phone him that's clever yeah
and then that might explain a lot of the
lower deck stuff that we saw but that
was just a thought I had today I just
suddenly like I remember the end of
lower decks and then season four was
coming I'm like
that could be and that's this sort of
thing they they seem to be really liking
to do because I mean they're really
crossing over all of these things and
you've seen that you've seen the
crossover episode I have what did you
actually think when you heard they were
going to do that what was your initial
thing
uh for my uh
opinion uh obviously Star Trek Discovery
sorry Star Trek strange new worlds and
lower decks are quite different from one
another
um now I know we're going to be talking
about the dynamic of
um uh strategy World season two has had
a lot of light comedy episodes which I
know that you've already talked about in
previous
um streams whatever about it's just the
right direction I think we can say yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and so
it's possible talking about it actually
live thinking about it it may be that
they partly made some of the episodes
lighter so there'll be more of a
continuity between lower decks and
strangely worlds so I don't know why I'm
suddenly thinking about that but it it
otherwise wouldn't it be more jarring to
try to slot them together in the way
that they did it it did know it didn't
work for me and I know a lot of people
are quite
um all right track yours they're quite
big uh fans of it
um Star Trek new Star Trek episode
yeah yeah it's it's not all that it's
not the whole case a lot of people are
saying look this is not quite what we
want we want a proper sci-fi drama with
thought compelling stories now as a
Stargate fan
Stargate sg1 as I'm a huge fan As You
Are
it did connect the comedy with the
Sci-Fi Stories the best fight ever yeah
it was such a wonderful
I don't know whether it quite works with
all the history of Star Trek in the same
way
you know so I don't know whether how do
you feel about that
I I'm with you on that I think the yeah
you need a balance I've always argued
real life has humor in it right it says
and when things get very dramatic that's
when somebody will make a take the piss
comment because it's our way of
um coping and you know we're leaving
things and that was always like Jack
O'Neil to me Jack O'Neill was like
people I've worked in the NHS and other
jobs I've had that are very stressful
there's always that one Joker anything
I've had the same I've had exactly the
same yeah
um so I think that's real life that's
why it felt real because his his humor
was real it wasn't slapstick it wasn't
ridiculous it was a you know in my ball
is waiting for him and he comes up and
goes I'm sorry I'm a lovely brunch that
is the sort of thing somebody might
actually say in that situation when
they're looking you know when they're
looking down on somebody and that's they
want to condescend somebody you know
it's um so that's why I thought it was
realistic and it's balanced I don't
think strange new worlds is and that's
my point but I love it don't get me
wrong I absolutely adore that
um but I think sometimes the humor is a
bit heavy and when you've got the
captain who would be a respectful figure
and he's there doing silly pirate
impressions
even though it was very funny I'm there
thinking yeah that's not that wouldn't
happen
in real life they made a point of it
didn't they in the crossover episode a
funny Captain what's going on
so I think I'm like well yeah because
he's a respectful character and people
are supposed to look up to him and you
kind of want to know your captain is is
on the ball
I'm thinking about
um how obviously you captured Picard and
the next generation was a very very
serious captain and there was an episode
in season four of the Next Generation
where Brian meets his old Captain
Captain Maxwell and he was saying how
his old Captain was much more jovial
much more easy going and it it it so in
some ways it does show that it's not
just the Star Trek series each Captain
has its own way his own or her way of
dealing with her or his crew but I'm
saying that I think that the informality
of the bridge crew in strange new worlds
is not the norm for a general Starfleet
ship in all the shows we've seen in the
past there's a way of acting in in a way
where you can have some banter you can
have some humor but it's not to the
level of as you say the pike going haha
gym lad and stuff like that it's it
doesn't quite gel with the 50 60 year
history of some of the Star Trek series
so maybe that's what you're picking up
on yeah interesting strange new worlds
for me I think stranger worlds is is Rod
and Bruce Star Trek and I think that's
what they've very much got in mind a lot
of the storylines feels like a
Roddenberry storyline it feels like the
first series of um TNG it feels like the
original series
um you could argue they're remaking a
lot of the original series episodes or
very inspired by a few
um and I'm not 100 convinced that's
gonna
work over six or seven season run
one of the things though that I would be
I would love to know your opinion on um
and it's something I've argued in my
other video was basically that this the
musical is one too many quirky episodes
and what I want now is I want three
episodes that of drama of the the thing
I I got me wrong I don't want Discovery
that's all drama and all action and all
running around I don't want that either
I think the first season of strange new
worlds had a really good balance I think
this is the evening
they've gone a bit silly and
well one rumor I keep hearing is that
strange new worlds is at risk of actual
cancellation
and then I see them do something like I
don't believe it I don't believe it I
think they're definitely getting a third
season they've already done all the
pre-production they're already doing a
lot of the work for it so I don't
believe it but I keep hearing the same
rumor
and from a couple of different sources
um but actually because of the strikes
it might not come back
um I'm certainly it will
um I'm 95 certain it's coming back but
they throw in episodes like the musical
and that to me feels like an episode
that you would put towards the end
of a season run
you don't put it in season two
what do you think um I think
first of all one of the aspects which is
a problem is that the actual each season
is so short uh at the moment we're
having only 10 episodes per season where
of course in the Heyday the Rick Berman
era we were getting 26 episodes per year
that's a lot of episodes
um and
um all the previous Star Trek series had
some really tough episodes It's not
against the Star Trek franchise
sometimes I have an idea it just doesn't
work every series and you're doing 26
episodes working 16 hours a day some of
them are not going to be so solid so
solid to do
um obviously they've done this crossover
episode which I liked uh they did
another relatively light-hearted episode
as well this is but the musical aspect
is a bit of a jump I mean it's never
been done before
um apparently Buffy did an episode where
it was a comic uh music it has been done
in season series I've never seen in
another format in another series I've
not seen it in sci-fi no um but I've
seen it in actually I know I have seen
this life I think
either Andromeda or
um the other one that was a bit like
Andromeda this knows
I think they did one um obviously the
like I said The Buffy did one but that
was a demon that caused like a spell
from the door for that to happen yeah
this could be a spatial anomaly couldn't
it it's something like suddenly hits
them then they start singing as to to
communicate they can do it in a way it's
sci-fi but I don't know that they all
know the words and they all know the
bank
I'm not sure that's going to work in a
series but it has been done in other
series I think Buffy was probably one of
the first ones to do it
uh but Star Trek the Original Series
used to have music in it you know they
would have to but to be honest
to Charlie like Charlie you're my
darling there's an episode where she was
singing to Charlie Evans who of course
had the power
um uh she sang a song for Spock
they had like a band at one point doing
this like nice hippies
um so I mean it's it's painful those
aren't the episodes people remember when
you go oh what was your favorite you
know the original series episode nobody
goes all that one with a spaces or that
one and they all go black and white face
guy or the folian web or something like
that don't they they talk about yeah
Doom stays a perfect example
um
when you look back on this season I
cannot believe I think people will say
what were your favorite episodes one of
the ones you remember and people will
obviously look at the crossover because
it was such a stupid idea that they did
so brilliantly well they really pulled
it off I said when it came out it's
either going to be brilliant or crap
there's no in between it
was really good yeah it can't just be
okay because it's such a mad idea if
they don't get it bang on it's going to
be silly and they've got it bang on
um so um but nobody's going to look back
and go well the musical was marvelous I
can't see anybody doing that and you
used to come I mean like in 10 years
time when you go strings New World
Series two what did you think well done
musical episode the one song they've got
to sing is star trekking across the
universe yeah if they don't it's just a
crime I would love that I'm sorry it is
the old musical form of Star Trek which
I remember hearing at school in 1987 and
even my mates who hated Star Trek and
there's a real stigma being a Star Trek
fan back then I was really I was always
a closet Trekkie back at school and even
though they were singing star trekking
across the universe
um
yeah yeah it was brilliant
[Laughter]
[Music]
through song and dance I think I think
they've kind of hinted that that is what
it's going to be I think I've seen the
trailer of it and they and like an
engine wave hits so they go like that
yeah but as you say they've got to learn
the lyrics
says something about this alien species
they celebrate with song and I'm
thinking I'm thinking it's like a
telepathic thing and it is a
communication I think that's that's what
it's going to be which is kind of sci-fi
they might get away with it they did an
episode of Voyager with a doctor
um he sings and then they invent a
better doctor than him and it was a way
it was so unfamiliar with music that
they used in a way it's not exactly same
as this format but as you've already
said music has been used in Concepts in
Star Trek before but not a full out
Musical that was one of those things
though and what they've done in previous
series is when you get into a bit later
down the line seasons four five whatever
and you've got an actor like Brent
Spiner who actually came from a
um variety sort of background he was a
singer a dancer and all these things and
you have actors like you know
um our name's gonna have my head oh God
ohura Michelle Michelle Nicole Miss John
Nicole and you've got something like
that who has got such a talent you will
have an episode and go you know we want
to show a bit more of the actor we want
to show you yes it's just weird that
doing it in the second season it's just
weird to do it's so early for me
perhaps that they don't then as you've
already said that might might not be
confident that it will have a very long
season or series if it's only gonna be
like three seasons of 30 episodes maybe
that's why they're coming in now yeah
I just wish they've done it as like a
Christmas special or something
you know what I mean it's just like a
surprise 11th episode
above me in the slightest
um I'd have gone you know a standalone
episode you know and yeah but the way
they've done it I'm just I feel a bit
robbed and I've just I just I just can't
help but I feel like no I was looking
forward now to the last three episodes
and it's going to be
um whatever this thing is they mentioned
the first episode this big threat that's
come in that's gonna explain it and it's
all gonna you know maybe a three episode
run into the big finale and now it's
sort of like
we're not getting that
yeah episode we're getting a musical and
then we're getting the finale and I have
no idea what the finale is going to
entail at all I mean you know I I know I
do like respect that they've actually
tried to make the episodes relatively
stand alone apart from this spot is now
suddenly very very human and laughing
and I never thought I'd see that art to
his character in even in a prequel kind
of thing
um but as you say normally you'd think
there'd be a builder towards some issues
some conundrums some
body of some sort of you know as you say
I've only got we've got the two episodes
we know about which are coming along
unless the Klingon one leads to
something at the end maybe that's a
loose link and they just got the Musical
one in between
I don't know
I don't know why they've done it
um as I say for me if you like musicals
you're going to look forward to it
like me I'm not interested
it's it's a waste and it's and I feel
robbed but but
God forbid that new track should be
anything but pigging
um divisive again
I mean it's with all the quite negative
press
that you know um secret hideout and
stuff have had in the last decade I know
it's not quite a decade is it like six
or seven years since I've had Star Trek
yeah I do have to wonder
who the executives are in charge when
somebody went let's do a musical episode
and it's going to be episode nine of the
season and we're not going to announce
until then I have to wonder
where was the person in the corner going
is that going to annoy as many people as
it is excites
you know we're already quite divisive
it's just gonna piss off a few people
and Alex Kirsten they go now it'll be
fine and then you know where was the
person with a common sense saying we
were already quite divisive
it's just gonna make it even worse it's
gonna make it kind of spiral it down
even more but then maybe they're
thinking that that's what they're
expecting anyway because whatever they
make they're gonna have somebody who's
going to be hating this is shite this is
rubbish so you know they might all I
think well look this is going to happen
anyway whatever we do so let's just do
it
yeah and I'm just thinking it's not that
there's there's a lot of people that
aren't going to watch this episode and
they've just started to get the numbers
up the numbers have not been great for
strange new worlds but there was there
were building it was a bit like Picard
the first three or four episodes the
numbers went great about episode five it
found its audience it really kicked off
yes and strange new world seems to be
doing the same the first few episodes
weren't great but about episode five
people and I think that's because partly
I think people binge it they don't watch
it straight away and they they then
they'll binge around episode four or
five sort of thing yeah um or when
somebody goes oh This brilliant episode
and you know the word amount as a thing
as well but
um so I'm so like you were just getting
going and you've turned off
half your audience
with announcing this and and like I say
I've got nothing against I'm not I'm not
a lot of people are angry about it a lot
of people are like what the f are they
doing really
um are they really are they bothered
about it oh man you should see some of
the comments I've had I've not looked at
all the stuff I mean I know that
obviously Discovery was very very
serious and that really pissed off a lot
of people as well and of course
yeah but it's like the extremes isn't it
on both sides characters you actually
like and for a character to actually
like you've got this gun I think you've
got to inject a little bit of humor and
that's the that was possibly one of the
reasons why in Discovery the characters
are so forgettable yeah because for me
anyway that's my problem with Discovery
I think it's beautifully made it's one
of the best looking shows on telly
um it's not badly written I quite like
this I think it's a good character
other than that
yeah she went to academy or something
didn't she yeah she's gonna be going to
Academy but that's a rumor anyway that
she'll be one of the teachers but people
like to but Tilly was because she was a
bit she was sweet and she was and she
was kind of funny
um but other than that
the actors I mean the scientists the the
the the is the albino the guy guys it's
unacceptable term the blonde guy anyway
um
the chief engineer do not care about it
yeah
I met the guy actually he's actually
really nice in real life horses
oh there you go but I mean it's one of
those things that if the character died
I wouldn't care in the slightest I'd be
like oh he's dead
um the Tara green thing escaped and at
him
um and you know like Michael's
been shot out of an airlock
no it wouldn't bother me if she rude
crying when she got shot out because she
cried in every episode yeah yeah which
is awesome I mean calm down with the
crying as well we don't I like to walk
if she was a
different character and that was fine
but I just don't know why but it's not
worked for her I like I was an actress
but I just don't like a character in
Discovery very much
yeah I just don't it's because I think
the whole show is just all I started to
the Joy sucked out of it and it's just
not worked but but anyway Strange New
World so far right we had the first
episode where they I've got my list here
actually I'm gonna go through the
episodes have we talked about any of the
episodes since I was last on with you no
we have all right so should we go
through the episode so is that how do
you want to do it yeah do it all right
so obviously the first episode was the
broken Circle which is the one where we
had this kind of Klingon kind of aspect
and people wanted to respark the war
which we had from Discovery
um there was a federation ship which was
um put together and it was going to be
instigating now I actually like this
episode
you hated it I know I thought it was
quite good so um
what it was
right so the other thing in the first
season where they had the Enterprise
been attacked and it did that spinny
maneuver and everybody really loved that
shot and those Torpedoes going past in
it isn't the Enterprise maneuverable now
um and massive inside huge bedrooms it's
lovely
um for me but then they do it every time
there's a battle now the Enterprise
starts spinning yeah
and I'm watching that going I've seen
this
um
the storyline didn't make a lot of sense
and I am sorry if you steal a federation
Starship even if it all works out in the
end you are going to get court-martialed
and but they just sort of went nah you
yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
you Billy don't do it again all right
naughty that's okay it's okay it didn't
it so but also the thing for half the
song that's gone I do not care What's
Happening Here There we go They're Gonna
trigger a wall are they
about that
um I think it's because I'm a big ship
guy I just like seeing another
Federation Starship even though it
wasn't I don't know
but then well another logical error in
that thing can we get we've talked about
logical error in the next episode
as Starship comes out the Federation
another Federation ship comes and Fires
at it very close to a Klingon warship
that looked amazing by the way the
Klingon warship I think it's D7 D7 yeah
oh man it looks amazing and that Klingon
warship did not take an opportunity to
fire
and I'm like yeah yeah yeah yeah
and then they just go and get pissed and
I'm like oh come on
mom please they look good they look good
the makeup was pretty good I like how
they've tried to sort of go right
we had horrible Klingons
so let's try and mix it up a bit and
pretend that they're just like
Northerners the weird plastic to the
north yeah exactly like Doctor Who or
something yeah they're like from a
different part of of the Klingon
Homeworld
um and and I'm just like yeah okay
well they're trying to fix a few of
their mistakes and and I I can respect
that they're trying their best
um but at least they did it at least
they didn't get the the ones from
Discovery and sort of like because I
thought we'd have the mix like um you
know the romulans um in Discovery uh not
into discovering Picard they mix them up
from the ones where they had the slight
v-shaped foreheads from the Next
Generation with the planer ones from TOs
and the mixer together and I think
that's where the northern thing came
from
they didn't go full plasticine heads
they just they put they had Klingons
that were more like the discovery season
one and the JJ Abrams clingers but yeah
yeah go that far and then they changed
the ridges on a fumes they're a bit more
like other ones we've seen and even
going back to some of the ones we've
seen in the movies where it's only a
couple of ridges and you know like 2006
out of different side of and Star Trek
Motion Picture yeah I didn't mind that I
thought that was quite cool so
um yeah I mean it's it's obviously an
episode which um had us issues and stuff
thank you thanks to Mike from Terra
Hawks it is I made it I 3D printed it
myself that is amazing
really good really good it was
astonishing yes punishing TV show I love
it I love that series I thought I'd show
it off because you can't buy these it
took me a data 3D printer as well it's
the biggest thing I bet if you made a
few
um
but thank you for the contribution
Andrew
um what are we saying sorry
basically we're talking about
um the Klingons and the episode in
general I mean obviously it it i i quite
liked it but I I could see why um you
know some of the aspects should say it
wasn't the most coherent story it didn't
exactly set up the Klingon Federation uh
relationship in a very realistic way um
so I could actually appreciate it only a
couple of years after the Klingon War by
the way yes exactly yeah and of course
they all look different as well so you
know yeah um so
um
those 20 minutes was just boring but and
no pike
apparently he's only recently become a
yeah either a father again or
um but he's got family commitments so
apparently he's not been involved so
much with season two because of Home
commitment definitely in the first two
episodes he was barely in it
um he's it has come through more terror
Hawks was a great show I love Terror
hooks
I loved all those I think terrax Jerry
Anderson wasn't I loved it yeah Anderson
yes it was um
I'm terrible they should bring back
Tower Hawks I'd love to see that I'd
love to say that God yeah CGI
um but um but yeah uh I just think you
pushed back production
if Anson Mount isn't available he's the
main man he's the main star you can go
oh well we can let the other shine
now is it because they can salute like
some of the other sort of uh Rick Berman
era where it's more of an ensemble kind
of thing so you can have an episode
which focuses on data on episode Riker
or you know maybe that's all about 10
episodes yeah I agree about that yeah
exactly these episodes yeah you can do
those episodes when you've got 10 every
episode is like let's sort of keep
saying the relay the real estate is
seriously valuable and you need to make
every penny count if your main actor
wants to have some parental leave that's
great
post-production back three months hmm
you know they obviously didn't do that
they also didn't know that they knew the
baby was coming nine months before
because that's how that works
so yeah they could do the math yeah
um so yeah I I wasn't impressed by that
episode two of this season I'm also
aspar era yeah uh this was the the court
case one with
um number one
um
and uh so obviously it was about the
antigenetic modification laws which of
course was linked up to
um DS9 and the others and um it was the
court case episodes and now um I've seen
quite a few court case episodes I have
to say compared to some of the others it
wasn't high on the list
um I thought that um measurement with a
data was probably one of the best ones I
also thought the Voyager holographic
writes in season seven I think it was
also another good one
um Wharf had a court one in DS9 there's
one's in the original series what do you
think of it
I thought it was borderline awful yeah I
didn't like this one it was illogical
um it was it was borderline nonsense if
I'm honest
um and they tried to build it up so that
there was that big clever reveal at the
end and I'm like
that was just such a cop-off but that
that way that they did it yeah it's like
oh a plus b equals what F no so so you
you didn't ask for Asylum
the captain has the right to break the
rules okay
um but you didn't ask but but you said
it was implied and I'm like that's not
how Asylum works you can't control right
now you can't just apply it got it or
you're not you know yeah years later and
and I'm just saying and anyway if you're
given Asylum
to the Federation that they could say
well okay you've got to silent that's
brilliant you're now a member of the
Federation and you can go about free
we're still kicking you at Starfleet
though
because you broke the rules and we have
standing laws that prevent people from a
genetically engineered people from for
being a Star Trek because we had that
you know Khan conflict yeah the Eugenics
ones but you could argue what about the
ship Bashir had the same principle he
was found out in DS9 season five and in
the end they let him off and his dad
went to prison for two years
yeah I went to prison what they realized
but then they changed the Federation law
that the Federation law did change
following that episode the problem was
they couldn't change the law for this
episode because
it's a particular equal yes and that's
what that's why I hate prequels as much
as I do because you know what's going to
happen you know what's in this episode
going well they're not going to change
the laws they're going to find some
loophole and they found a loophole but
they didn't that's the problem they
didn't find a bloody loophole they just
did it and they're just offending it was
a cup of yeah
huh that's fine now now it isn't also um
when we reviewed it on my show 100
that's what they kind of used as an
excuse didn't they saying that the
captain is allowed to occasionally break
the prime directive and we don't have a
goal there as well actually Kirk got um
bloody
um demoted and that was from stealing
the Enterprise fire breaking yeah for
breaking uh the rule of the um what's it
from the commander what's it called the
chief and uh display in director order
that's what it was with him yeah
um I I also the episode I also thought
that the pacing was a bit too slow it
was quite a long episode and
um it might have done better if it had
some sort of b b story or something
maybe just a just to fill it up a bit I
don't know it it I preferred episode one
to episode two let's put it that way
yeah I hated both and my problem was I I
didn't like the end of cysts a strange
New World season one
I thought I know you did you hated that
episode
I hate him I remember you saying
bringing Kirk back was awful it was such
a bad decision now don't get me wrong
I've watched him since they're not
terrible they're just not as good as the
first eight the first eight episodes
were so good that then it tailed off at
the end and I'm like um
but um this one it's just it started
week
but then
we get to the third episode
tomorrow and tomorrow and tomorrow
which I featured Kirk again
and I was okay with it
and then I'll give you my
one I liked
to be honest I just thought it was a
clever story I thought again it was a
time travel episode which was a bit sort
of like
somebody appears we need to go back in
time
and it was just very like there was no
reason for what happened but I didn't
really care because the story worked I
liked it and then she walked up and
there's Kirk and the things had changed
again I again I don't know why the
conflict was that why that would have
happened but if that happened
um just don't answer just go with it I
actually like Kirk man I the guy that
they've got playing him I thought that
was my main problem in the first series
I thought the guy that got playing him
he's too scrawny he's got a weird hunch
thing going on and I just didn't like
him but in this series we I think we got
to see a bit more of him he was a bit
more light-hearted it wasn't as serious
as the last two episodes where we saw
him yeah
um and I I actually got by the end of
this I was thinking I like this guy I
think this is good I still don't think
they should have brought Kirk in this
early again I think it's another
indicator that maybe this series
timeline
well well there's alternate timeline
which we can talk about in a minute but
I'm wondering whether this season isn't
going to go past season three or four
and they don't there's no intention for
it to
that's the only reason I can think I'd
bring Kirk in this early because it's
getting closer to when they stop it you
mean yeah I don't see how it's gonna
work
um
um but I thought this episode was clever
I thought the relationship between hey
and this I'm sorry I don't I can't
remember her name the security officer
um so lahan
um I just thought it was relationship
the only thing irritating me slightly is
um Kirk's now a chess genius
when did that happen
uh he actually beats [__] his very
first scene in the very first episode of
the visual series oh well I didn't I
don't remember that so yeah it was it
was where no one where no man goes
before
spot beat him they were playing 3D chess
in their very first scene and and um and
Spock was still quite emotional I
haven't watched the original series for
years he was playing on the very first
time right then I don't mind that scene
so much things at least it's dragging
something back from the Original Series
yeah
1D chess or 2D chest whatever you want
to call it compared to 3D chess is easy
so at least the only thing was that I I
think he made a lot of money I mean
people are gambling a lot of money on
chess
um but but that's that's another there
it was it's true then actually I find
that scene a lot less irritating
um if they if that was if that was right
they need we'd seen him play chess in
the previous thing so yeah because it's
growing I mean he is growing on me uh
he's foreign
Quest just said
um it's definitely I think we've had to
get used to him because he's very
different from uh Chris Pine and William
Shatner's versions
um and
um it's funny because the actors Ethan
heck and that's amount as Pike and Spock
have been easy to get used to whereas
Paul Wesley is a bit different in his
version of Kirk and I tell you what
though I saw a side-by-side image of um
William Shatner about uh Paul Wesley's
age and Paul Wesley
and there's a similarity isn't it and
you kind of look you know a bit alike
not a lot but yeah but that's right at
that age sort of thing when um although
Paul Wesley's older isn't he's in his
early 40s and of course
um uh Kirk in the original series is
about 34 when he was Captain yeah that
was what they they base it on the ages
they were supposed to be so because um
Kirk's character is supposed to be quite
a lot younger isn't he he's supposed to
be five or six years so he spoke to me
in his late 20s yeah
um whereas obviously yes I know the
actors a little bit older but
um but yeah he's grown up which is
interesting yeah I don't hate him as
much as I did put it that way that's
good okay so maybe if you watch Paul
Wesley in the last episode of season one
again in the future maybe you'll find it
a bit easier to watch the second time
around I I watched him in the run-up to
the season coming out this season coming
out and I I have to admit that's when I
realized saying no I didn't I don't hate
these episodes as much as I sort of did
first time I don't use the word hate I
usually hate in the terms of Television
which isn't um
I hate the
um I don't know I hate the Russians
invade in the Ukraine or I hate it if
somebody upset to my wife I hate that
I
I hate something yeah yeah just the way
you turn it is the way you turn it yeah
it's um I've disliked it but it only
because it was compared to the other
episodes which was
um I just yeah
but what did you think of the episode
I'm generally I think generally it was
good I think that my major issue I don't
know
it's not the right word but but
what's the discontinuity with the Khan
with the Eugenics Wars and that Khan was
of course supposed to be taking over the
Earth in 1992 which means he would have
been born in the 1960s or 70s and this
point we've got another Khan that was
born probably in about 2012 or something
we assume about 10 years old in the
scene
um now I understand why they've done it
and
um you know because you know the real
world we're catching up with uh
hypothetical future ideas for neutral
series but
um I I kind of thought I don't know it
was coming anywhere we knew that this
was going to happen but I just kind of
and I've been watching such a all my
life so I kind of always think well that
was not how they did it back in 1966
when we had a car you know what I mean I
really no doubt about continuity
um yeah I have a love hate thing with
content I think sometimes Canon and
things that you've got to
you've got to give the writers the
opportunity to change things slightly
and for this case they kind of have to
do it that way because they needed to be
slightly in the future because of the
bridge thing and the way they were doing
it and then it had to be a child because
lahan couldn't kill couldn't kill him
basically yeah exactly for the future so
um so that it had an emotional impact so
I know why they did it
um I that didn't bother me so much as
the actual story of the episode I don't
think was
the story of why she went back in time I
can't even remember it now I only
watched the episode a couple weeks ago
uh yeah something happened well we had
the temple agents didn't we at one point
yeah yeah I can't even remember why back
in time herself because the episode was
more about the relationship between her
and Kirk which actually works the
dynamic it did seem to work for me yeah
so that's the only thing that would
bother me maybe the reasoning for
actually going back in time was a bit
weak other than that
um so the actual story was a bit weak
but I think maybe they even did that on
purpose a little bit because they were
focusing on those other things
um
you needed time for that relationship
thing to build sure and they're going to
end up embedding the musical episode yep
yeah oh yeah
um you know what you you are you're like
the actual um your channel everything
you are the person to actually say this
is going to be shy but what if it's
really good are you gonna come back and
say you know you know I was so so I'm so
wrong it was the most fantastic episode
I've ever seen Star Trek and since I was
um always I will always say my opinion
and I'll always be honest if I if I
don't like something I'll say I don't
like it and I will and I would I'll try
to explain why
um and that's I think something I think
that's what you've done tonight you've
done that today well a lot of hate
channels don't do that they just say
this right oh they come up with some
nonsense political reason and they are
they attached stuff to it I've been
wrong a couple of times I've said I'm
not sure but when I tried to do the one
thing I won't do is I will not say the
musical is going to be crap because I've
not seen it so I don't know
you're disputing some doubts some doubts
initial doubts about how it might
actually I'm saying I think there's a
reason I wish it wasn't happening now
because I want some sci-fi now we've had
a couple of fun episodes I want some
sci-fi now yeah so that irritates me I
feel like I'm being robbed a little bit
but that's not the episodes fault you
know I mean if this was the 11th episode
or a bonus Christmas episode or
something that'd be fine no problem with
it at all yeah I agree
yeah but also I'm not excited about it
I'm not I'm not angry about it but I'm
not excited about it because I don't
like musicals and to be honest it
doesn't matter if the episode's good I'm
still going to come we're going okay I
can watch it I'll never watch it again
because I don't know what it's doing
what it's doing you know if they did a
murder mystery episode I'd be like all
over it I'm like I'd love a good murder
mystery I've watched the [__] out of it
um but you know if they did if they do a
teenage angst relationshipy episode
Staffing Academy that's gonna be doing
that anyway
um I'll give it a go but I won't be
excited yeah I'll be like okay well
let's see what this is about but oh God
but they've been doing that they've been
doing like the horror episode like with
the gaun episode last season and they do
the one with like the um the episode
where there's it's like a submarine kind
of hiding in the nebula kind of thing
nearly remake the Wrath yeah yeah they
did that with it yeah so but a lot of it
I think they're throwing and hoping
it'll work and not using Star Trek like
a freaking toy to I think to show them
so so good because Star Trek greenshield
did it
um
yeah Adam Chandler the Apple Christmas
Carol with Ryan Reynolds and that that
was quite good I quite like that
um I'll watch it I'll watch a musical
Christmas I'll watch a classic and
that's what I mean they should have made
it a Christmas special but anyway
um
so yeah that that's my reasoning but if
it's a good episode I'll come back and
I'll say a good episode but to be honest
my feelings that I wish it would have
been a a Sci-Fi episode and I still
don't like musicals they still get
that's still going to be true yeah um
try very hard not to say some it's going
to be [__] I might say I I'm not sure
about this I said I wasn't sure about
the crossover idea
but what I said was it's going to be
brilliant or awful because it's such a
risky idea
um and I'm just but I'm so glad it was
great I'm I'm very open to change my
mind
as well which I think a lot of maybe
some people aren't so good at you know
that and once they get locked into a
thinking they stick to it you know I I
pride myself on
I'm more than willing to have an
argument with somebody and actually lose
and I don't know because if you can
change the mind I will I will because
I've learned something I've grown from
it you know
um well I think that one thing that we
do in our respective channels is that
we're not hate channels
um you know we are not going to say
something's wonderful if it's shite but
we're not going to just say this is
terrible this is all everything is you
know I mean there's loads of channels
out there we all know we're not going to
give up the names but we know what we're
talking about and they are they
something proved very very popular but
just literally being negative and
spewing hate about everything in in
whatever uh TV or film franchise that
they focus on I hate that I hate that
um so you know like I said it's um
yeah the easiest way to get 100 000
subscribers is say something
controversial
and um and you know do something
controversial and make people angry
because they'll they'll subscribe to
listen or whatever but but you know I'm
I'm not I'm not interested in I I try to
have an honest Channel
breaking up a little bit Mike
what's up
nope
[Music]
um let's have a quick look uh crossover
already teased in lower decks episode so
I'm hoping we'd get it and we did yeah I
think so why not
um the boys musical episode was great
they did it again they did it a
different way so that was awesome
um recent Star Trek serves a purpose it
makes enterprise look like Shakespeare
you know I was actually thinking about
this Bob the other day
for one thing I was thinking
I quite liked the start of Enterprise
it's been a long road you know I'm
singing it to myself earlier today and I
was thinking I actually quite liked it
um
the new track does make old track look
good you know it doesn't even makes
enterprise look really really good it's
a shame
you're not coming through very well Mike
um
yeah and I like some people yeah we have
to give the animation a fair go because
it might be
the um the dial up
um but it might be what we get with SGU
so oh we've lost him so I'm pretty sure
we'll be back in a second though
um oh Mom yeah what to talk about hmm
um but
the thing with new track at the moment
I think the format of 10 episodes ago
is a problem because I think it doesn't
give us the character development that
we're used to from Star Trek we have
lost out on a lot of those episodes that
filled out certain characters and things
the I keep saying this is but it's the
the time now for the new track is so
valuable they haven't got time to take
their time
and introduce characters in different
ways or see characters in different
um scenarios and things it ends up just
being they've just got to crack on with
it get on with it get on with it and
that I do think that's a problem from
conception that
and then there's nothing they can do to
get around that because they've got 10
hours that's it
instead of 20 before you know over seven
seasons
the rumor I keep hearing though is the
strange new worlds was only ever planned
to be three seasons
and that
isn't that that rumor doesn't seem to
want to go away
um
I I have heard recently that there is
serious consideration going towards that
there won't be a third season because of
the strikes and things
I don't believe that personally I think
they've done too much work on
on already then because they were
already they were they were they were
about to start filming when the writer
strike happened and they ended up
closing the set and but they were they
were literally about to start filming
this they've done a lot of the work
already
um but if that is right and that we only
get three seasons and it was only ever
planned for three seasons and I do think
all of a sudden a lot of the stuff going
on with Star Trek at the moment makes
sense
um um because they're acting like a show
that's been on for six seasons already
they're acting like a show that's coming
to an end already
so
yeah
um
they did to be fair they told a lot of
story in the expanse in three seasons
and
it worked and there was a lot of story
to tell
I was thinking about this with the other
um
day though actually was the expanse and
this is this is not till my Star Trek
now we'll talk about the expanse for a
minute was the expanse too conceptual
for the Casual Observer it's got the
Casual audience because you get when any
show you get a Core audience say a
million people
and then you get the Casual audience
that audience that comes in and comes
out sort of thing
with Star Trek when you've got episodic
shows and things you you can jump in you
can miss an episode and it's okay you
know and you can jump in or you can go
I'm not feeling this one I'll watch the
next one sort of thing
you couldn't do that with the expanse
you had to watch every single episode
you had to take every single episode
really seriously and there was some
quite disjointed episodes I'm thinking
the first season
you could watch that and then the second
season start it it did feel very much
like well what about all that stuff from
the first season what's going on is that
is Thomas Jane dead and you know all
this sort of thing and like what
happened and then there was a random
episode when it's the guy on the rocket
ship and it was the the engine that they
used was invented he invented it by
mistake and you assumed shoot off your
space because that was a chapter in the
book so they did it they did they kept
it quite
you know realistically to the book
but it made casual the Casual watches I
mean the real sci-fi Nutters
us guys we loved it because it was so
realistic and so on the ball and so you
know
um loyal to the books and things and it
was proper sci-fi hardcore sci-fi
but the Casual Observer couldn't watch
it and I think that's why it never
really got the audience base it needed
so I'm not going to say the expanse
failed because it didn't it didn't it
wasn't a failure but I'm also going to
say that maybe it didn't succeed
and maybe it didn't succeed for that
reason that it was too
conceptual it's too heavy and I do think
that's why shows like the foundation
have to go on Apple where they can do TV
shows that you know were a serious
um sci-fi because they don't have the
audience base and they will have they
need shows like that where they they
care about the hardcore fans they're not
as bothered about you know the
casual Observer casual audience
so they want to bring shows like that
that people will come to so they're a
big fans of the foundation novel Series
so people will come to Amazon and sorry
um Apple to watch them specifically to
watch them they will get apple just to
watch them
Apple named shows like that they need
shows that are going to drag that
audience across
whereas Prime other big ones Netflix
even
they need shows that cross genres that
actually lots of people will watch
because these shows are expensive
it's just a thought I'd love to know
what you guys think
um
I don't think so but it might have been
right next door to conceptual yeah no
conceptual isn't to him the right word
actually but it was it was
it's very realistic very serious sci-fi
and I want to say that is it's grown up
sci-fi I've struggling to find the right
word for it really it's it you know
but the main the main thing I'm trying
to talk about is that it
you needed to follow each episode
and there'd be stuff talked about in you
know episode particularly in like the
first season but then follow through the
rest so if you missed a couple of
episodes you could all of a sudden have
something much later that makes
absolutely no sense
um
and that's what I'm sort of talking
about that it was really serious serious
sci-fi
um
I would recommend Apple
go and get it for like a month
binge all the brilliant shows binge Ted
lasso binged Foundation binge
um uh one small step binged Invasion and
binge all these shows
and then cancel it for like six months
and then get it again for just for a
month
um and just binge the new shows that
have come on the new movies and things
there's not enough material on there to
keep
so get it bins what you want to watch
turn it off that would be my way of
doing it
um
but guys I think I think what we're
going to do is I think I'm gonna end
there because we've lost Mike and he's
he's not coming back so
um and there's only so long I can talk
on my own I I you know I haven't planned
for this so well never mind
um don't forget to go over and subscribe
to M cubed we had the live just before
this where we were talking to Greg who
was a really fascinating I'm going to
try and get him on Sidetrack and we're
going to have a uh Star Trek episode
we're just going to geek out on some of
the Sci-Fi because he really was
absolutely fascinating and For All
Mankind thank you what did I call it one
small step or something For All Mankind
um absolutely fascinating
um it reminded me of sort of like a man
in the High Castle it's that sort of
thing again very very cool idea that the
Cold War the the space race has been run
by the Russians
yeah
uh
uh I believe in you j4 I monologue ago
I mean I could I can talk crap if you
guys throw me some questions I can I can
answer them I'll do my best but just
come up with stuff to stop your head
when you weren't expecting it is a
little bit more difficult
um when are you next live
um go on to M Cube so there's a link in
the description we're gonna add it I've
realized Paris I'm sorry mate you're not
on my
um connected channels but you will be
very shortly
um
but
um he is there is a link in the
description to go over to M cubed so
please go over and subscribe um Harris
is is you know he's pushing for 200
subscribers and his channel is better
than that he's live every almost every
night he's talking about all the movie
news if you love movies you love
television you have to go and subscribe
there because he tells you all every
single day so get over there subscribe
to M cubed
that's where you want your movie news
from and I appear on there sometimes
Matt appears on this sometimes stormy
goes on there and upsets everybody
sometimes and you know we try to help
Harris because his channel deserves much
better than that and he gives us an hour
of his life every single week
um I will be live on Sunday
we're going to be talking about the top
um sort of those are top 10 best sci-fi
from the naughties
list we're going to be talking about
that we're going to be talking about the
survival guide again and how we're going
to get through this bloody
um
strike and when they stop once all of a
sudden material stops
David B
right wolf pack
I quite liked it
I actually think Paramount have got some
really good shows at the moment I really
liked wolf pack don't get me wrong it's
old school uh actually Mike is back we
can have him back in
hello I don't know what happened there I
don't want my background's changed but
um
so sorry about that sir
we've moved on anyway we're talking
about streaming services at the moment
so I've just done my I'm just going to
talk about Paramount have you ever did
you watch have you got Paramount Plus
have you seen any shows on there I
um how do you feel about the whole
Paramount uh situation with their
finances it's not looking too good at
the moment is it no they've got about a
year
I have one year left but I tell you what
they've got some really good shows on
there um like this is this wolf pack
show that has Sam show Gallery in it
it's like werewolves and stuff and it's
a bit
teenagers oh I'm aware of what we're
gonna do oh I fancy you let's have a
snog there's a bit of that but there's a
few times
you know and you think Michelle Michelle
Geller is one thing and then she turns
out to be another there's some quite
cool special effects
um I'm I really enjoyed it I then went
on to watch Rabbit Hole with m key for
Sutherland that's really good lots of
twists and turns again and now there's a
show called lioness
um which again uh Zoe salamander and
um a few other people in it oh it's
changed again
um only because it slows down my speech
if it's on it slows down out of sync
yeah that's why I've got rid of the
green screen that's why I've just done
it yeah yeah using the green screens for
lives because it does affect the the
things yeah yeah but
um but it's it's really good Paramount
because obviously Panama's got some
really good movies on there and because
it's Paramount so now Paramount plus is
worth getting it's slowly creeping up
the thing it's about the 11th um biggest
Channel now
and it's growing it's it's equal like
Roku and that sort of level at the
moment and for subscriber numbers but
it's creeping up and creeping up
um in 12 months time though do not be
shocked if they merge with somebody like
Max or Netflix or apple or something
like that
it would get them out of trouble
wouldn't it and then of course it means
in the franchise would can there be
shared on a higher rating streaming
Network and then potentially it could be
actually a good thing you know you've
had amalgamations before when you've got
a like a channel in trouble
um but of course um you know uh I mean I
I'm not watched it I've watched a bit of
Apple TV stuff I've watched a show
called
um there's a show called something like
after tomorrow something that is it's a
really weird series with these hover
cars and these sort of stuff and that's
quite interesting something like after
tomorrow that's quite good
um but go back to Paramount yeah I I
don't know I mean the fact of the matter
is there's a lot of competition with all
these various um streaming channels
um and even the big ones like Disney and
stuff are having a trouble at the moment
you know they're cutting their costs
um and it's it's just the fact that
people you know they don't have too much
money to spend and and they're going to
be a little bit more careful and you
know it might have been a few years ago
he said oh I'll get this streaming I'll
just get five stream mean sites because
normally all the shows you like they're
all scattered all over the place and
that's the problem so and of course you
know this is why and I've always said
this I'm a very uh a big fan of actual
physical media
um because in the end um it's like it's
like you know if I I've not really
watched start at Prodigy that much I've
seen the first couple of episodes I will
watch it especially after all the live
action stuff finishes soon but it's the
the problem is is like it's like someone
coming into your home collection and
taking all your favorite Blu-rays DVDs
because oh we can't have it anymore you
know so it's the home of Star Trek
but it's the the temporary home of Star
Trek it's kind of like Paramount anymore
exactly exactly it's going so what I'm
saying is that's what puts me on
um at the moment it's buying a paywall
on Prime
um but I'm cold in a couple of months
it'll just be on Prime and then the
second season will be Premiere and on
Prime yeah and as a prime
um original
oh as a product but they didn't well a
little broadcast but they didn't make it
it was actually yeah but they've
apparently they've put some money into a
louder Paramount to finish it
um
yeah there's there's some there are some
big problems within this at the end of
the day the streaming Wars was lost by
everybody
um everyone lost
um Netflix even was struggling and
Netflix are generally the ones that are
doing the the best
um but they've actually secured a little
bit by the this new rule with the past
Paramount password sharing they've
actually done quite well out of that so
their numbers like 2 million subscribers
or something when all there's been
people thought oh crap I'm gonna have to
stop
um sharing oh just passing you know
Netflix password
um yeah so they've done okay ever
they've just about kept the top spot
Disney
are in massive financial problems and
that's going to be that's that that's a
big point of that is down to Disney plus
but Disney plus has affected their whole
business because one of the things they
did was they've affected Cinema because
I honestly believe a lot of people and I
because I've thought it myself
why am I going to spend all that money
to go and watch this new Disney movie
when it's only gonna when it's going to
be in Disney Plus in a couple of months
yeah exactly you'll wait a couple of
months to save yourself the money yeah
and and going to the cinema is expensive
so you've got to really want to go you
know it's um and I and I I love going to
the cinema I adore it I do I haven't
been for a long time but also the fact
is that people's home systems now you
get big TVs you get a good basic a good
sound you know it's not like back uh Go
and show my age when I was a kid I used
to have a 4x3 TV I'll go and see a movie
and it's huge it's got the bass it's got
the stereo and you know people's home
entertainment systems now a lot better
when video shops appeared in the in the
80s you know that nearly killed Cinema
um and it came back and you know and and
it bounced back sort of thing
um I don't think it'll ever kill Cinema
because it'll be a thing but I think
we'll have a lot less Cinemas
um my cinema they turned into a looks
like
all the chairs
beautiful for one they're miles apart
you know yeah
eating crisps
that's what someone said to me like why
do you like go to um Cinema and
literally have like a huge meal with hot
dogs and popcorn and donuts and like
like almost like grazing like a cow in a
farm yard or something shut up I watched
a bloody film you know what I mean I buy
myself a cheap bottle of a cheap bottle
of pop and a cheap box bag of popcorn
because the popcorn's always stale and
the Pop's always flat so I don't bother
um but anyway so but the chairs will go
back and they've got loads of space and
you know how comfortable it's out I I we
went to watch I can't remember what it
was now but we went to watch a film that
my kids wanted to watch and my wife had
to poke me because I'd fallen asleep
[Laughter]
it was the Barbie film was it no it
wasn't there
um that's a film that's confusing
parents what the hell is that all about
everywhere I go in Portsmouth where I
live there are signs for this thing
everywhere I don't want to see it I
don't want to see Oppenheimer but I
don't want to see it's like oh my God
most advertised movie I've seen in years
it's every single bus stop every single
bill oh there's this woman dressed up as
a Barbie doll no thank you
I was we were talking about this on the
stream a minute ago but um one of the
things was because it's quite a grown-up
movie it's not it's you know it's it's
about matriarchivity patriarchy and all
this stuff there are some very serious
themes going on this movie but all
little five-year-old we always want to
go watch it if I've actually talked to
my one of my bosses actually for my day
job the other day and he took it he took
him yesterday and she come out and going
I don't know what I've Just Seen well I
um you know I was expecting a kid's film
and I'm like and my kids coming out with
a lot of questions
it's okay you know it's a very confusing
movie but hey it's done very very well
so I I have no idea I I if people think
it's quite if it's well done I don't
know I mean like I said it's it's
part of the experience I mean I always
come out and then for hours later I'm
going oh a bit of popcorn yeah yeah
exactly it's like a sort of like an
after thing yeah
um but yeah Mike but I I have to admit I
think twice about taking my kids to the
cinema because it's like by the time and
then they're bitching they want nachos
yeah
um don't eat half of because they you
know they and the cost of
expensive I'm like
I've spent but me and my wife have got
the um the cards where you get to you
know unlimited oh okay yeah that makes
sense all the time all the time
um so I yeah I love it
um
so so yeah but um
I actually think apple is one of the
best ones at the moment particularly if
you're a Sci-Fi fan I think they've got
all the best sci-fi episode things at
the moment Foundation Foundation is very
good foundation season two is is just
coming up soon isn't it that's coming up
soon already come out it came out that
we're on the second episode I think or
Thursday oh wow okay
but yeah I just think I think the future
is going to be that the the streaming
services
they're going to have to well I think
they thought it was going to take over
the networks and networks were going to
die and now it actually seems that I
think the networks are making a
Resurgence
TV is still doing okay it's terrible I
mean live TV is it's terrible there's I
don't watch one thing people still watch
it
um but the thing is the networks will
still do 26 episode Seasons that the oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah
suppose
um
sci-fi though especially the UK I can't
think that one part of Doctor Who
there's not one British sci-fi Network
series I can think of right and I have
to think I don't watch
anything on TV
services
I watch some stuff on catch up I mean
we'll watch stuff yeah yeah yeah
but generally speaking we watch
everything through streaming and um and
I've got
but because of this channel though I
sort of the wife also say well we've got
too many costumes money and I'm like oh
no the channel page should babe I need
to watch these TV shows and I'm so it is
terrible that I'm not going it's I I
don't want to watch it it's research and
I get away with that somewhere
um but I've got
um I've obviously got Prime I've got
Netflix we've got Prime yeah we've got
Netflix Paramount I've got Apple
Beauty's got two you've got a load
though you've got a whole lot by the
sounds of it I'm trying to think what
else I think that's all of them I've got
I've got Paramount because I've got five
um
I think that's all the ones that are
pretty much available in this country
other than if you want to get add-ons
through yeah we've got Disney though
have you got Disney oh and we've got
Disney so I've got stuff as well that's
long oh wow okay I don't watch as much
Disney as I used to I've sort of I
watched the style
um I don't watch YouTubes YouTubes for
children
um
I keep saying that I'm not saying that
my kids always watches YouTube they
don't watch anything else my my two
watch a lot of um not the other one
what's the um tick tock
yeah they watched like Tick Tock as well
and I don't get that no I don't know
what that's all about at all I uh we've
got a tick tock Channel and Matty does
the videos for tick tock all right when
he remembers okay and um uh yeah he he's
just better at that than I am I can't do
shorts he's really good at it I wish
he'd do more of them because he's really
really good at it
um and um it's I think you need a
specific style for it and I don't
yeah I've never never
um all I see is like Tick Tock someone's
like going oh that's it it's like five
seconds I just don't understand
yeah exactly or like a purpose and then
like
yeah there are people out there doing a
really good Tick Tock shorts and YouTube
short videos as well
um there are some great ones it's just
you've got to sift through a lot of crap
to find them but um
yeah let's think well it's an
interesting point the track gate has
just come up with them I'm gonna have to
go so I promise to wife I'd be done at
nine so oh yeah sorry that's my back um
now there's me waffling while you were
gone
um so I understand why some people don't
call Enterprise classic Trek but for me
it is it is for me as well it's because
it's first gen second gen Star Trek
um none of the new Trek shows have come
back close to how great even that show
was Picard season three and strange news
are closer but not that close I think
Picard season three
is the only new Star Trek series that I
would say
comes close to that second generation of
Star Trek I agree entirely 100
I was actually getting up early on a
Thursday when it came out over here to
watch it and I was excited to watch each
episode I I'm not excited to watch
strange new worlds I I you know I I
watch it and I look forward to watching
it don't get me wrong the same level as
it is
Notch isn't it I'll watch it in you know
from work I won't get up early to watch
it which I was with Picard season three
but I tell you what I'm honestly I
watched Picard season three back through
again
wasn't this good I didn't enjoy it as
much Once In The Nostalgia and
everything had gone
and I knew what was coming a little bit
but actually I did speak to somebody
about this and they said I think you
watched it too soon you needed to to let
it you know like a final simulates it
assimilate the the actual whole thing of
what it was about yeah maybe I watched
it a bit too quickly but um all the
mistakes in it just compounded me I'm
just not like it's a mistake after me
I've seen it I've seen it twice I will
give another re-watch
um it's weird with certain shows that um
I watched them the first time and I
disappointed and then I watched it the
second time it's not so bad
um and um like I said it's kind of like
it's um
it's rare for me to be the other way
around where I've watched something I've
enjoyed it and then I've liked it less
in the second viewing so I don't know
whether that's the um I don't know I
know it's not quite sure really but um
at the end of season four Enterprise
after this is in the conflict
on the nx01 refit then
oh no season three end of season three
season four was after the zindy yeah so
if they'd have done the because
obviously they the Enterprise came back
from the battle with the zindy battered
if they'd have done the refit then
would we have got a fifth season of Star
Trek Enterprise
uh
uh well I know that the refit was
potentially going to be happening in
season five
um and it's gonna be the Romulan War
because Roman War I know that
um
are you saying that if we'd have seen
the refit at the beginning of season
four the last season it might have
actually built up interest in the show I
think it would have been more
interesting I think it would have built
up there'd have been a bit of excitement
around the show whereas there's always a
bit of a Wayne you know mid mid thing
season four is 10. season 4 was the best
season
um but there's always a popularity thing
and then they tend to pick up again
towards you anything even like classic
shows like friends and stuff around
season four five it became you know
popularity weighing a little bit and
then it picks up again towards the end
it doesn't happen to do that um so I
think if they'd have done if they'd have
done the refit and got a bit of
excitement through
I think we'd have got I think we'd have
got a season five I think I loved
Enterprise I thought Enterprise was so
good I still think Scott Bakula I've
still was too used to him being
um on Quantum Leap but I I liked it I
thought it was a good thing
I was on board
and I just think that you know it really
was when it finished in 2005 it actually
got canceled
um it started it was never quite the
same after that you know and um it's
still like I said um because season
three was the closest we've got since
that era and even if nothing else
happens we got that and I'm very very
pleased we've got it and I like I said I
think in subsequent re-watches I think
I'll still like it quite a similar
advertise I watched it the first second
time but yeah I never know I'd be like
you but I think I think it's Star Trek
2.0 like I said actually it should be
3.0 technically shouldn't it because
we're on the third gen of Star Trek yeah
this we're in the third we're in the
third era
really but yeah that's how I'm starting
to think about it now I just don't think
about it's not really the Trek I think
about it the way I think about JJ Abrams
Star Trek
that's a very polarizing uh element to
Star Trek as it always has been since
2000 well new trackers as well yeah I
don't think of it as really Star Trek if
you think of it as just JJ's Star Trek
it's not quite as annoying and you can
just enjoy it for what it is um Len
flares and all
um but that's how I'm going to think
about Star Trek now well I know you need
to wrap up so let me just quickly say
I've enjoyed
um we're reviewing but we haven't got
time I know you're gonna shoot off but I
have enjoyed um because
um well season two so far
um let's see what the musical episode is
like and then hopefully we'll get a good
season finale
fingers crossed
um I will be putting a video out
tomorrow
um to give you a little bit of a sneak
peek it's something I've talked about a
few times and it's the Stargate Universe
animated movie
well I came up with the idea and I'm not
going to go into the details now because
the video tomorrow but for you guys that
have actually bothered coming to watch
us live and it will be on the patreon
first thing in the morning as always
I came up with an idea that they should
do a Stargate Universe
um animated movie
because I thought it's the only way it
would actually get made because it's a
lot cheaper to make than a live action
um and we heard lots of rumors that sort
of were making me think that maybe that
was actually a possibility
um like Warner Brothers like a couple of
the actors being approached and but us
not knowing what for blah blah blah okay
one of my sources and I'm not gonna go
into things but one of my sources then
messaged me after I talked about Anna
live going and all they said was how did
you know that
oh and that then started a little bit of
a conversation that is talking about
tomorrow's video now it is very much
room and I'd say that repeatedly in the
video I've even undenight about whether
I should even release this information
because I'm not confident about it
but I think the possibility I talk about
it just as a possibility
and I explain why I think it actually
could make sense
and why actually
this is not only the thing is that it's
not just a plan
it might have actually already been made
and that wow okay that's the bit that
I'm sort of like going or in the process
of being made I should say that the
it'd still be mean now but there's a
reason why
they've changed that's basically Amazon
have changed a lot of their plans and
the strikes of me be accelerated this
okay
um but it's only coming from One Source
I don't know how they got the
information I don't know where the
information has come from so I cannot
say it's any more than a rumor sounds
interesting though but it's an
interesting rumor so we will talk about
it
um and yeah that video will be out
tomorrow
okay I'll check it out definitely
absolutely um and I am going to get
yelled at by people going you're all
joking but I'm like I can't I I that's
partly my fault I had it from Miami so
I'm sorry about that no no and I talked
to no I mean people when I release this
video people are gonna yell at me oh I
think
for the moment
and Paris is I talked about Harris with
Harris a few days ago about this and all
of a sudden I'm not sure I should do the
video or not I don't know if I should do
it
um and we just decided
um you're gonna go for it okay says I
hated my idea of a wormhole extreme
animated it would have been a comedy
series I hate that idea you're just
wrong it's great
I thought it was just a nice way of
doing like a comedy sort of series
because I really I'm a big fan of lower
decks I think it's great I think it
really adds something to the franchise
yeah I don't like that it's in Universe
particularly so I was just thinking look
it's a great way of doing sort of that
type of show because it's a show I love
and if you hate lower decks you're going
to hate this idea obviously
um
but it's out of the universe so it's
still starving but it's not in universe
so you can I just thought it open a lot
of possibilities to sort of take the
mick out of Stargate and have a joke
with Stargate right without it being
Stargate without actually being a yeah
the way around it yeah yeah it was a fun
way and this would only this would be
years down the line if everything else
worked and it was but you know this dude
this would be like we've already had two
or three seasons maybe a couple of
movies this would be way down the line I
wouldn't you know I wouldn't do this
straight away sort of thing but I just
thought it'd be fun oh it was or
something you wouldn't even have to do
an animated movie really a comic book
series just something which just
actually get something actually out
there in whatever form
you know different bit of fun something
but something you can have fun with and
the creators and you can tell the
creators though Canon doesn't matter
just have fun have fun with it and I
think we could see something really
interesting but so um check out um yeah
you're wrong so
no don't lose him as a subscriber no no
no he's obviously not I mean it's if
this is all opinion and to be honest it
would all be about execution as well if
they did an ex well not extreme series
as well as it could be done and it was
respectful to the original series and
everything and you watched it with an
open mind you'd probably love it but
it's like everything else if they do it
badly it'll be awful
um and it's all about execution look
look there's a series a couple of years
ago you know like Satan fighting crimes
it was cool what's it called Lucifer oh
yeah I never saw it I never saw it but
yeah I know of it it's absolutely
fantastic
um it's the stupidest you know idea
Satan goes on holiday to Earth and
starts fighting crime it's ridiculous
but it was executed so well it was
worked look the Star Trek episode
yesterday the crossover between a
cartoon and live action that works an
idea but they executed it brilliantly
and at the end of the day any of these
ideas if they're a risk
if it's done well you'll love it if it's
not does that go with the musical before
we sign off
[Laughter]
unfortunately probably not so I just
staring I like stir it going no no but
only because
I don't like music
I don't like them either
um I
like I
I original
um Charlie in the Chocolate Factory
you know what I've actually got a copy
of that I don't even think of it as a
musical it's just such a good film it's
just it's perfect
um and yeah and so hey you never know if
they're really catchy songs
yeah yeah but I will only be watching it
once I would be amazed if I ever watched
it again
well well I look forward to getting your
review of it or like your opinion when
it comes out so I will be surprised if I
even can watch all of it oh come on
I'd be surprised
okay well you can watch it with the
sound often
[Laughter]
mine they're trapped in a wall oh
they're in the wind they're in the wind
now and but I'm gonna go into with an
open mind and I'm genuinely not going to
carry anything and I'm gonna go look I
will give this a go
um and if it's if it's bad I'll tell you
it's bad and if it's great I'll tell you
it's great
um I'll look forward to getting your
opinion whatever it is you know
I'm not looking forward to it but I
don't
and just wish it was a Sci-Fi show
how how am I here oh go on how am I here
and there
I was just working it was a very big
surprise to me and people like that yeah
yeah but just as many people hate it but
it's um you know
uh it's a polarizing idea it's a risky
idea
tell you what you should do you should
review it you should actually film
yourself and actually do one of those
things where you can actually know you
can put the actual uh episode without
the sound on and put a Time on it and
watch the whole episode and obviously I
know it's a bit dodgy putting on YouTube
with the copyright stuff but it'd be
great to get your reaction of it that'd
be fun I sometimes will do a video when
I'm watching so I'll stop and or
sometimes you can hear it in the
background and I'll sort of like go what
the
and uh
it's a long road that's a proper song
get in from there to here yeah and then
as soon as I start doing start oh I
don't know they're going to do Bohemian
Rhapsody and if they actually if the
lyric is Subspace Rhapsody
what if they put in surprise theme song
into the actual Musical
I'd probably I'd love that I've said an
idea now I'd like that and a lot of fans
would like that so I reckon that's
something I'd like to I suddenly had
this idea much as they've done that like
Pike singing it's been long I'm not
gonna sing because I can't sing but that
would be interesting I would like that
yeah
yeah actually I hated that when they did
that but that's one of those things is
that you look back now and I'm like I
love it it's all right it's different I
really liked it I do it well the updated
version of season three is where they
gave it a bit yeah
anyway thank you so much Mike for thank
you I'll be honorable as usual
um technical issues as usual sorry I
apologize if it's not you it's me so I
wouldn't really I really wouldn't worry
about it
um and hey I kept it together like the
professional that I am I do the same on
my channel I'm just like constantly
professional you know I just yeah I just
said
at least somebody say something in the
comments I could talk about
um at least I came back I was
like I was stuffed up to reset my router
and everything that was really bad yeah
I'm sorry
um thank you so much guys again thank
you don't forget to go over and
subscribe to M cubed there is a link in
the description I'm going to be banging
on about this because his channel
deserves to have a lot more people on
and if you like movies and television
and you want to be kept informed but
can't be asked to read deadline every
day
Harris's channel is the place to go so
get over there and subscribe to add mine
too don't subscribe to Mike song
get over there subscribe to all these
things
um I have not got a link in the
description for your channel so but I
will put one in in five minutes there
will be one there when you're there m
cubed is awesome and so is Mike's solo
on podcast particularly if you like
British old classic TV shows because you
put those little Clips on things I love
watching those I know you keep getting
trouble with them copyright because
you're putting those out yeah
I'm not there for the money I'm just
there to share stuff that I enjoy [__] I
know you like that's what these channels
are supposed to be there for I'm gonna
get into I'm gonna get in serious
trouble one of these days for saying
something but I it'll be I will mean it
whenever I say it but I'm gonna it's
only a matter of time
um thanks guys we'll see you soon and uh
Michael see you in a in maybe in a month
or so when we'll talk about yeah
whatever next yeah I'm definitely come
back great thank you very much see you
later
ha